when the u.n mission in sudan announced
it will be facilitating talks between
the military and political parties the
head of the army agreed to be part of it
but on monday general abdel fattah
al-burhan announced the army was
withdrawing from the talks
the military institution shall not take
part in the current negotiations to give
room to the political and revolutionary
powers and other patriotic and societal
parties to agree on a technocrat
government from the civil community to
undertake the affairs in the coming
period of time and i hope these forces
will engage in genuine and serious
dialogue to restore the unity of the
people and steal the country away from
any existential threats
the announcement came as hundreds of
anti-military protesters staged citizens
in various parts of the capital khartoum
for more than seven months they've been
demanding the military handover power to
a civilian government and return to the
barracks
we want to end the military rule which
has become a burden to the sudanese
since october we want to show that most
of us are against military rule and we
want a civilian leadership to achieve a
democratic transition
this sit-in is our way of expressing
these demands
this sit-in now in its fourth day is in
front of a hospital where at least one
protester was pronounced dead from
protests on june 30. nine people were
killed that day and hundreds injured
when security forces used tear gas and
live ammunition to disperse mass
demonstrations
those here are demanding the security
forces be held accountable
if you look at the people here what
unites them are the deaths of those
killed by security forces we have their
pictures everywhere here and that is why
the top demand is justice for those
killed political parties who are part of
the resistance to military rule should
take note anything that does not include
justice and accountability will not be
accepted
more than 100 protesters have been
killed in anti-military demonstrations
since the military took power last year
the response of security forces to the
mass protests on june 30th has resulted
in not only one but four sentence in
khartoum protesters here say despite the
repeated use of force they will not end
their sit-in until their demands are met
hiba morgan al-jazeera hartung